the anaconda is the world's largest
snake and among the most deadly an
anaconda can swallow whole an animal the
size of an average dog
it kills by wrapping itself around its
prey tightening its grip until its
victim can no longer breathe
herpetologist paces rebus studies these
fearsome creatures for a living most of
the time he manages to escape their
wrath but today his luck runs out
unable to escape the anaconda Strikes
Back it sinks its fangs deep into a
Seuss's flesh his survival depends on
extricate in his hand what would you do
in the situation should you pull your
hand straight out of the snake's mouth
push your hand further down the snakes
throat or hook the snake in the eyes the
answer is B push your hand further down
the snakes throat
poking it in the eyes won't it let go
more likely a good poke will only make
it dive into the water taking you with
it pulling your hands straight out of
the snake's mouth actually pushes the
teeth deeper into the flesh
that's because anacondas teeth bend
backwards
to safely extract yourself from the
Anaconda you have to actually push
deeper into the mouth and off the teeth
and that's how you survive an anaconda
bite